well summertime means traveling for many
families and sometimes that includes
pets
if you're taking to the skies or hitting
the road here's a look at some ways to
make traveling easier with your pets
and even some options for you if they
have to stay behind
she's world travel that literally has a
european passport uh yeah she travels
everywhere
we get a room that takes dogs
and i welcome you know and take them to
the beach or wherever we're going
traveling with your pets can be fun but
it can also get complicated
according to a survey by the american
pet products association
67 percent of households own a pet
and the u.s travel association reports
37 percent of pet owners
like carrell bully take their animals
when they travel
she's harnessed in the front seat
because just like kids
you know they can fly around the car and
you don't want that to happen
when you're hitting the road remember
safety when you need to add the water it
makes a little both
kendra george with petsmart shares some
advice for the trip
dehydration is one of the most things to
really be tentative to when traveling
we also do like harnesses that would be
able to strap to like their cars
um we have car seats as well for dogs
if they're more larger you know they may
be getting something
like a cooling pad in the back
if you're flying keep in mind airlines
have different policies and fees
most allow only dogs and cats you must
also provide current vaccinations
for traveling by pain playing i would
say maybe doing like uh
giving them some supplements or like
maybe asking your vet to prescribe
um maybe some like anti-anxiety
medication as well
but if things get complicated remember
there are several options around the
valley
like day cares and overnight boarding i
found this spot in the southwest valley
this is our individual yard
jason mccallum of adventure pet resort
says his business is equipped with
cameras
on-site training even grooming we have
them in common
all the time dropping off for just a few
hours to the whole day you know
literally up to 12 hours and since we
are 24 hours
we work a lot with the medical industry
kennels or sweets your pooch will be
pampered
while you're away i wouldn't travel
without her she's the best little
traveling companion i could ever have
and
you know traveling is stressful uh and
and you know she does help relieve it
plus she brings so
many smiles
so many smiles there well remember
trains and buses also have their own pet
policies best advice
don't forget about your pets while
you're planning that next getaway last
minute arrangements
can get pricey